So adding colors wouldn't increase the latency, but it would
increase the bandwidth. What bandwidth means, is the amount of information
that can be transmitted per unit time. And it doesn't matter
if there's a start-up time. Right, the start-up time is the
latency. That's how long it takes to start sending a
message across. That's how long it takes for the start of
the message to be received. The bandwidth is, once you've got
some part of the message across, what's the rate that you
can send information? So, this is going to be measured
in terms of units of information divided by units
of time. So bandwidth could be measured in terms
of bits per second. On the Internet this is
often measured In Mbps, which is megabits per second
or million bits per second. I haven't yet explained
what a bit is, and in order to understand
information, it's important to understand what a bit is.